déjà vu alles wie vor vier jahren ja sie
haben es ja gerade miteinander auch
besprochen dass die umfrageinstitute
teilweise daneben lagen
ich habe selbst die beobachtung gemacht
wenn man mit amerikanischen
geschäftsleute in deutschland etwa
gesprochen hat dass die öffentlich sich
geäußert haben
für joe biden aber hinter vorgehaltener
hand doch enorme sympathien für donald
trump geäußert haben insbesondere wegen
der wirtschaftlichen entwicklung wegen
der getroffenen entscheidungen zu
steuerentlastungen und regulatorischen
fragen und da gab es möglicherweise
schon etwas wie eine schweigespirale
dass also die eigentliche wahlabsicht
aufgrund des öffentlich erwarteten nicht
geäußert worden ist und vielleicht sehen
wir das in dieser nacht auch und selbst
vielleicht trägt das dazu bei dass genau
das eintritts bevor die meisten sich
gefürchtet haben und was auch ich für
schwierig halte nämlich eine phase der
instabilität in den vereinigten staaten
weil es eben kein klares akzeptiert das
ergebnis in dieser nacht gibt ich will
noch einmal ein bisschen tiefer
reingehen weil das ist ja jetzt wenn es
so käme das scheint sich eben wieder
durch selbst nicht ein leichtes oder
knappes versehen der
meinungsforschungsinstitute mann lag wie
vor vier jahren in diesem fall radikal
daneben man da hat kein
meinungsforschungsinstitut hat es
vermocht diese stimmung vorauszusagen
breite teile der politik haben es nicht
wie wie kann man so stark daneben liegen
und was sagt das für das gespür aus oder
dass das auch die politik für das land
für die bürger hat möglicherweise
unterscheidet sich die veröffentlichte
meinung unterscheiden sich die in der
öffentlichkeit geäußerten meinungen doch
sehr erheblich von dem was die menschen
tatsächlich denken und wenn das so weit
auseinander geht das öffentlich erwartet
dass öffentlich für richtig gehalten
dann neigen offenbar sehr viele menschen
dazu auch in umfragen gar nicht ihre
eigentliche absicht zu äußern
und das ist sicherlich auch ein
bedrohlicher umstand für den inneren
frieden für die stabilität einer
gesellschaft wenn man die absichten der
menschen gar nicht mehr voraussagen kann
weil es eine so einen so großen
unterschied gibt zwischen dem was als
sozialadäquat empfunden wird was
geäußert wird und was tatsächlich
gedacht wird das ist für die innere
stabilität einer gesellschaft sicherlich
auch ein kritischer befund auch etwas
worüber wir dann in europa und
deutschland nachdenken müssen inwieweit
das bei uns vielleicht ebenfalls der
fall sein könnte in denen sie haben
gerade gesagt natürlich unter anderem
die wirtschaftlichen entscheidungen von
donald trump einer der gründe warum man
jetzt noch mal wen wählen würde aber vor
allem in diesem jahr das große thema
natürlich die korona pandemie und dort
haben auch viele gesagt sein umgang
damit könnte jetzt dafür sorgen dass er
sein amt eben verliert jetzt sieht es
doch nicht so aus wie unwichtig ist auf
einmal kroner in den letzten zügen
dieses wahlkampfs geworden man muss ja
sagen amerika mit unglaublichen
todeszahlen aufgrund dieser pandemie
kann das wirklich einfach so in den
hintergrund rücken
kurzbach das können andere besser
beantworten als ich aber eins ist es
richtig ihr kollege jan schäfer sprach
er über den last minute swing dance in
wahlkämpfen ergibt und im fall der
vereinigten staaten sind die
überraschend positiven wirtschaftlichen
zahlen sicherlich einen rückenwind für
donald trumps kampagne gewesen
die haben auch möglicherweise abgelenkt
von der schwierigen bilanz der pandemie
politik von trump und auch von anderen
und es zeigt sich vielleicht dann wird
man in
ihnen sagen dass ein altes wort eines
beraters von bill clinton richtig ist
sie kolonie stupid das also in den
vereinigten staaten insbesondere
wirtschaftliche fragen den
entscheidenden ausschlag geben könnten
aber das werden bei im nachhinein sehr
klug analysiert bekommen von den
experten jetzt ist zunächst einmal die
hoffnung dass es zu mindestens ein wie
auch immer es aussieht akzeptiertes
wahlergebnis möglichst bald gibt weil
vereinigte staaten die sich über einen
längeren zeitraum mit sich selbst
beschäftigen gar vor gericht mit sich
selbst beschäftigen die also eine große
lücke auf der weltbühne öffnen
das wäre gewiss keine gute nachricht
dass wir die schlechteste nachricht
sogar was denken sie denn wie das ganze
wenn sie jetzt auf die karte blicken die
wir auch eingeblendet haben in ihren
augen wie wird sich das ganze am ende
doch noch drehen
das weiß ich nicht ich weiß nur eins so
wie es jetzt aussieht gibt es keinen
erdrutsch sieg für keinen von beiden
insbesondere auch nicht joe biden darauf
haben ja viele in europa und in unserem
land gehofft und deshalb werden wir ab
heute vormittag auch stärker auf uns
selbst schauen müssen was tun eigentlich
die europäerinnen und europäer was tun
wir in deutschland eigentlich jetzt für
unsere interessen in der welt und für
einen neustart der transatlantischen
beziehungen
es wird so oder so notwendig sein für
mich da gibt es jetzt heute zwei
konsequenzen die erste konsequenz ist
wenn man sich auch die überraschungen
gelungen ansieht wir können als deutsche
nicht immer nur mit den küsten sprechen
und wir müssen auch stärker in den
dialog mit fly over country also mit den
staaten zwischen hollywood und wall
street um smart schlagwortartig zu sagen
also sollte der deutsche außenminister
darüber nachdenken wie kann auch unsere
präsenz die kann der dialog den wir
führen esser gestalt werden brauchen wir
neue goethe institute in oklahoma city
wunder oder brauchen wir neue
generalkonsulate im mittleren westen
einfach um dort erst gespräch zu suchen
mit den menschen die vielleicht für
unsere werte und interessen noch gar
nicht sensibilisiert sind und das zweite
ist dass spätestens jetzt in dieser
situation doch klar wir müssen als
europäerinnen und europäer auf der
weltbühne für unsere interessen selber
einstehen das wird uns keiner abnehmen
und wenn wir ja auch immer im weißen
haus zukünftig türen wird wenn wir da
attraktiv sein wollen als
gesprächspartner als handelspartner
dann müsse nicht auch mit einer stimme
sprechen wir sind noch der größte
zusammenhängende wirtschaftsraum der
welt wenn wir nicht unsere interessen
selbst vertreten es wird keiner tun
insbesondere die usa aber wer auch immer
regiert nicht mehr
ganz aktuell hören wir christian lindner
dass der bundesstaat arizona an beiden
gegangen ist das ist so ein
hoffnungsschimmer also noch für die
demokraten für joe biden bringt aber am
ende wenig wenn dann die staaten im
norden also michigan wisconsin
pennsylvania eben an jump gehen das
vielleicht ganz aktuell als nachricht
noch rein
sie hatten jetzt die goethe institute
und die ganzen lehren die man ziehen
könnte jetzt aus einem möglichen
nächsten jumps in weit ist dass das was
wir eigentlich schon vor vier jahren
besprochen haben und was die leeren
längst hätten sein können hat man in den
vier jahren nichts gelernt und das
bedeutet ja dass ganz ganz viele eben
heute früh wir haben es jetzt kurz nach
fünf eben wieder aufwachen mit diesem
erneuten schock der genau das wieder
abbildet wie vor vier jahren also nichts
gelernt
die debatten ähneln sich da haben sie
völlig recht
und auch in deutschland haben wir
bestimmte konsequenzen nicht gezogen es
gab so die hoffnung es kommt joe biden
alles wird anders
meine prognose ist selbst würde joe
biden gewählt werden wird eben
hinsichtlich der interessenunterschiede
es eben nicht ganz anders werden an
präsident biden wäre im stil angenehmer
mit dem könnte man leichter vielleicht
verhandeln aber in der substanz der
position etwa bei den lastenverteilung
man in unserem westlichen
verteidigungsbündnis der nato werden
sich die position nicht sehr
unterscheiden deshalb müssen wir uns
auch als deutsche ehrlich machen gibt
für politische diskussionen etwa um die
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik
einfach so im glauben darauf maya im
zweifel wenn es mal um die frage auch
unserer sicherheitspolitischen
interessen geht dann können wir uns auf
die vereinigten staaten verlassen und
die werden schon bald höhere lasten
tragen als die europäer oder auch als
die deutsche nein ganz sicher nicht egal
ob krank oder beiden da müssen wir uns
ehrlich machen und müssen unsere
strategischen interessen selbst
wahrnehmen dann werden wir allerdings
automatisch auch attraktiver für wer
auch immer im weißen haus regiert für
die amerikaner ich glaube diese wahl
nach besucher so eine zäsur oder sollte
eine zäsur sein für unsere usa politik
aber auch für all das was ihr auf
unserem kontinent miteinander politisch
gesprächen will doch mal ganz kurz auf
diesen schock zu sprechen kommen den
ganz ganz viele in deutschland als
solchen empfinden werden wenn sie gleich
aufstehen den fernseher zum ersten mal
machen oder zum ersten mal auf bild.de
nach den stunden des schlafs schauen am
morgen und dann erleben dass das ganz
anders gelaufen ist als sie da ist
vorausgesagt hatten oder vorhergesehen
hatten viele viele in der politik werden
das so erleben auch einige in der
bundesregierung werden dass er so
erleben wie beispielsweise der
vizekanzler der ganz offen hier joe
biden ja die daumen gedrückt hat wie er
gesagt hat wie werden die sich verhalten
müssen wenn sie jetzt aufstehen was
werden diese reaktionen seien
von dort christian lindner in ihre liste
kann man auch den bundesaußenminister
aufnehmen wir haben es in der politik
mit realitäten zu tun mit denen muss man
umgehen und im fehlerfall eine nüchterne
bilanz
wir wissen ja noch nicht wer es wird
aber ich bin einmal unterstreichen
meine prognose ist es wäre eine illusion
zu glauben mit einem anderen präsidenten
würde eine völlig andere amerikanische
politik gegenüber europa verbunden sein
das wird da man aber eben nicht der fall
sein
also all diejenigen die glauben wenn joe
biden im amt ist dann werden wir
entlassen aus unserer
selbstverpflichtung 2 prozent unserer
wirtschaftsleistung zu investieren in
unsere eigene verteidigungsfähigkeit das
wird mitnichten so seien auch joe biden
wird darauf bestehen also so oder so es
ist erstens zeit für einen neuen
realismus zweitens dafür dass wir als
europäer eine gemeinsame sprache lernen
und unsere interessen gemeinsam auf der
weltbühne vertreten
und drittens es ist zeit für einen
neustart auch des transatlantischen
dialogs und der kann sich dann nicht nur
beziehen auf den kontakt in das weiße
haus sondern sehr viel stärker musste er
auch umfassen den
zivilgesellschaftlichen dialog hat eben
die stichworte genannt einmal darüber
nachzudenken ob nicht nötig ist die tote
und generalkonsulate ein mittel wären um
auch mit den amerikanerinnen und
amerikanern selbst ins gespräch zu
kommen die nicht an den küsten wurden
wir jedenfalls haben wir sehr viel
nachzudenken
nach dieser wahlnacht egal wer gewinnt